>>> SO FAR NO REPUBLICANS HAVE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR WHAT IS
KNOWN AS THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
AND THAT'S NOTABLE BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY POPULAR WITH
THE GOP IN THE PAST.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BILL, WHAT
YOU SEE IS A SERIES OF
TRADE-OFFS.
SO HERE ARE THE FACTS ABOUT WHAT
IS IN THE LEGISLATION AS IT
STANDS NOW.
FOR STARTERS, IT WOULD BE THE
BIGG EGEST CLIMATE INVESTMENT I
U.S. HIRSTRY WITH $369 BILLION
SET ASIDE TO COMBAT GLOBAL
WARMING, THAT INCLUDES CONSUMER
TAX CREDITS ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, SOLAR ROOF PANELS AND
OTHER THINGS THERE ARE BILLIONS
OF TAX CRITICS TO FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES TO GET THEM TO INVEST
IN CLEAN ENERGY MANUFACTURING
THIS IS KEY.
THE BILL ACTUALLY SUPPORTS
EXPANDING INVESTMENT IN DOMESTIC
OIL AND GAS EXPLORATION ON
FEDERAL LANDS AND IN OFFSHORE
FEDERAL WATERS.
IN FACT, FOR THE NEXT DECADE,
ANY NEW WIND OR SOLAR ENERGY
PROJECT ON FEDERAL LAND COULD
ONLY BE APPROVED IF A NEW LEASE
IS APPROVED FOR OIL AND GAS
DRILLING AS WELL.
ON TAXES, THE BILL ABANDONS TAX
INCREASES OPPOSED BY
REPUBLICANS, INCLUDING RAISING
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE, THE
PERSONAL TAX RATE OR THE CAPITAL
GAINS TAX RATE.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES CHANGES
TO THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM,
INCLUDING A MEASURE ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL WOULD EMPOWER MEDICARE
TO NEGOTIATE THE PRICES OF
CERTAIN COSTLY MEDICATIONS,
WHICH IS GARNERED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE
OBAMA CARE SUBSIDIES SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE YEAR
UNTIL 2025.
AND AS FOR THAT CARRIED INTEREST
LOOPHOLE THAT SENATOR SINEMA
NIXED, EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
ELIMINATING THAT IN THE PAST.
BUT WORD COMES TO MIND HERE,
THAT WORD IS COMPROMISE.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THIS,
SENIOR
" RON BROWNSTEIN.
RON, A STRAIGHT UP LIST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S LEGISLATIVE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, BY THE WAY,
CALL SEVERAL OF THESE
BIPARTISAN, THE BUDGET BILL
LOOKS TO BE ON TRACK NOW.
YOU HAD GUN LEGISLATION,
BIPARTISAN, THE CHIPS
LEGISLATION GOT THROUGH,
SEMICONDUCTOR PRODUCTION IN THE
U.S., ALSO MEMBERSHIP FOR SWEDEN
AND FINLAND.
WHEN YOU ADD THAT UP, HOW DOES
THAT STAND IN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS FOR GETTING THAT
KIND OF LEGISLATION PASSED AND
THAT PERIOD OF TIME?
>> YEAH, THEY ARE ON TRACK TO
GET A LOT DONE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT THAT PASSED
THE HOUSE THAT GOT BLOCKED IN
THE SENATE, PARTICULARLY VOTING
RIGHTS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO DO, ON SEVERAL OF
THESE WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT LIST.
AND THIS BILL IS AS JOE BIDEN
MIGHT HAVE ONCE PUT IT, A BFD.
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS
SOMETHING THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN SEEKING FOR 20 YEARS SINCE
PART B OF MEDICARE WAS CREATED
UNDER GEORGE W. BUSH.
AND THE CLIMATE INVESTMENT,
WHICH ARE THE BIGGEST
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSITION TO OUR
CLEAN ENERGY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EVER MADE, ESTIMATES
THAT WILL BRING DOWN U.S.
CLIMATE EMISSIONS BY 40%.
AND POLITICALLY GIVES DEMOCRATS
REALLY THE FIRST, I THINK,
POSITIVE THING THAT THEY CAN GO
TO YOUNG VOTERS WITH AND SAY
YOUR VOTE MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
PREVIOUSLY THEIR MESSAGE WAS
MOSTLY NEGATIVE, STOP
REPUBLICANS FROM TAKING AWAY
YOUR RIGHTS.
THIS IS SOMETHING POSITIVE AND
IT DOES ADD UP TO A LEGISLATIVE
RECORD, EVEN WITH MANY PARTY
PRIORITIES THAT WERE STILL
BLOCKED BY THE FILIBUSTER.
>> THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR
VOTERS THAT YOU OFTEN SEE IN
POLLING IS THE ECONOMY AND
INFLATION, AND BERNIE SANDERS,
OF COURSE, WHO CAUCUSES WITH THE
DEMOCRATS, HIS CRITICISM OF THIS
BILL IS THAT IT DOESN'T HIT THE
BOTTOM LINE FOR MOST AMERICANS
IN THE WAY MANY ARE DEMANDING.
SOME WAY TO HELP THEM GET
THROUGH AND OVER THESE HIGHER
PRICES.
IS THAT, FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT WITH THE MIDTERMS
THREE MONTHS AWAY, IS THAT A
MISS IN THIS BUDGET LEGISLATION?
>> I THINK THAT DEMOCRATS DO TO
RON'S POINT NEED TO GO OUT AND
HAVE SOMETHING CONCRETE THEY CAN
PITCH TO VOTERS.
AND THIS IS IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY A SLIMMED DOWN
VERSION OF THE BUILD BACK BETTER
LEGISLATION THAT THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE FIRST PUT FORTH BUT HAS A
NEW NAME.
NOT CALLED THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT.
NAMELY BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
ACUTELY AWARE THAT INFLATION IS
THE PRIMARY CONCERN THAT VOTERS
HAVE.
WHEN YOU TALK TO ECONOMIC
ANALYSTS THERE IS NO EXPECTATION
THIS BILL WILL IN ANY TANGIBLE
WAY ACTUALLY HELP BRING DOWN
RISING COSTS BEFORE NOVEMBER.
THAT IS JUST NOT A REALISTIC
PROPOSITION, BUT IT IS A
MESSAGING STRATEGY AND I THINK
FOR DEMOCRATS IT IS ONE THING TO
BE ABLE TO PUT FORTH
LEGISLATION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
STRUGGLED AT BEING ABLE TO
MESSAGE THOSE WINS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY STRUGGLED
WITH FOR MANY MONTHS AROUND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
AND I'M CURIOUS IF THIS IS
DIFFERENT AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
PITCH IT TO VOTERS.
THAT'S PART OF IT.
NOT JUST PASSING IT, BUT
PITCHING IT.
>> RON, THE SORT OF
CONTRADICTION IN THE MIDST OF
THIS, RIGHT, IS THAT YOU HAVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN ACHIEVING MANY
OF HIS LEGISLATIVE GOALS, IN
SOME CASES AGAINST THE ODDS IN
RECENT MONTHS.
IF WE WERE TALKING TWO WEEKS
AGO, WE WOULD HAVE SAID ANY
VERSION OF BUILD BACK BETTER WAS
DEAD.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE
DEMOCRATS CERTAINLY PRIVATELY
BUT MORE AND MORE OPENLY
QUESTIONING WHETHER JOE BIDEN
SHOULD EVEN RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024.
RICK WILSON OF THE LINCOLN
PROJECT, HE TWEETED ABOUT THIS
EARLIER TODAY AND SAYING,
QUOTING HIM HERE, JESUS,
DEMOCRATS CAN'T ORGANIZE A
TWO-CAR MOTORCADE, BUT CAN TURN
THE GUNS ON THE LEADER OF THEIR
PARTY 90 DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT CRITICISM
HERE, THAT THE PARTY
SURPRISINGLY IS NOT RALLYING
AROUND THE PRESIDENT IN THE
MIDST OF THIS?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK THE 2024
CONVERSATION IS REAL, IT HAS A
LOT TO DO WITH BIDEN'S AGE, AND
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING AWAY
NO MATTER WHAT LEGISLATIVE
ACHIEVEMENTS HE HAS.
THE MORE IMMEDIATE QUESTION, THE
MORE IMMEDIATE PROBLEM IS THAT
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING AMONG
DEMOCRATS HAVE FALLEN --
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS HAVE FALLEN
BELOW 80%, AND THAT THREATENS TO
COMPOUND WHAT IS THE TYPICAL
AFFECT GOING BACK 150 YEARS
WHERE THE PARTY OUT OF POWER IS
ALREADY USUALLY MORE MOTIVATED
TO VOTE IN A MIDTERM ELECTION
THAN THE PARTY THAT HOLDS THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND I DO THINK THIS ACHIEVEMENT
DOES HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
RESTORE FAITH IN THE NEAR TERM,
LEAVING ASIDE 2024, AMONG SOME
DEMOCRATS, PARTICULARLY YOUNGER
DEMOCRATS.
HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS AMONG YOUNG
VOTERS HAVE BEEN TERRIBLE.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
BIG -- CAN I ALSO PUT ONE FLAG
IN THE GROUND, ALL OF THIS
REMINDS ME OF WHAT BARACK OBAMA
WAS ABLE TO DO IN 2012 WITH THE
AUTO BAILOUT.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMBINED EFFECT OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BILL,
ENCOURAGING DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS, AND
THE SEMICONDUCTOR BILL,
ENCOURAGING DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING, I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE BIDEN OR WHOEVER IS
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IN 2024
GOING TO RUSTED OUT INDUSTRIAL
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING THE CASE
THAT WE HAVE INVESTED IN YOUR
PROSPERITY THE SAME WAY OBAMA S
AWAS ABLE TO DO ACROSS THE
MIDWEST.
>> A LOT IS HAPPENING.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING YOU